you and baby
[Music]
welcome to another ColdFusion video in
this video we're gonna take a look at
the state-of-the-art in solar power
energy generation specifically solar
power plants this may seem like an odd
idea but it's really been picking up
steam in the last two years or so in
this video we'll take a look this video
is brought to you by Squarespace one of
the easiest ways to build a website the
ColdFusion website I'm building is
coming together nicely so hang around
till the end of the video to see how
it's progressing and also get a special
offer this month China just completed
the world's largest floating solar power
plant and it's now operational this is
kind of strange because China was once
seen as the Loews largest polluter but
now maybe they're cleaning up their act
the plant built by Chinese photovoltaic
manufacturer Sun gray floats in water
two to ten meters deep interestingly
this plant was built on an old coal
mining site that has been filled with
rainwater because of the mining
activities the water there is otherwise
mostly useless the advantages of such a
plan is that no land needs to be cleared
and the water also provides the ambient
cooling for the plants environment
reducing long-term damage from heat the
downside it's only 40 megawatts of power
output for comparison Australia is
building a 330 megawatt land-based solar
power plant and a 650 megawatt one is
being built in India but if you want to
take a look at the world's largest
land-based solar power plant it all
circles back to China they have a
whopping 1500 megawatt solar power plant
and for those of you wondering one
megawatt can power roughly 400 homes
so let's zoom out on our perspective
here a little bit how did the largest
solar power plants compared to the
largest nuclear power plants he is a
general table of all the nuclear power
plants over 1,000 megawatts as we can
see they range from about 1,000
megawatts all the way up to almost 7,000
so we can say solar power plants are
about half the average here so let's
take a look at coal the average here is
a little higher maybe 3 to 4,000
megawatts so the solar plant output is a
bit under 1/2 here so this is very
interesting a lot of people usually
laugh or a very skeptical of solar power
but as we can see the largest solar
power plant already has half or just
under half the energy output of the
average large-scale coal or nuclear
power station
what's more about all of this is that if
you look at the years in which these
solar power plants were commissioned
it's all mostly been happening in the
past two to three years this is all very
new stuff so what this means is that at
this point the technology is at its
worst efficiency and the most primitive
it will ever be solar power plants are
only going to get better from here on
alright so this sounds all pretty good
but what about the energy storage how do
you store the received energy from the
Sun to use at night well there's a
couple of options you should go down the
battery road with the implementation of
a new use for an old technology
specifically battery packs like Tesla's
power packs they are the utility scale
battery packs that are used in
California and also used to currently
power entire islands in Hawaii from
solar power with this method the off
demand storage issue could be solved
for power plants that use solar thermal
energy directly storing excess energy in
molten salts is also a solution
one of the more interesting methods I've
heard of is a little experimental it
involves storing energy within rock
cavities such as mountains using
pressure a friend of mine who I met at
the st. gallen symposium is doing this
with his company our case I've already
briefly mentioned him in my Europe video
but we'll be doing a video together on
this technology is pretty interesting
stuff this experimental method could be
a future solution to the off-peak energy
problem with power plants that are in
suitable geographical locations another
problem with solar is that obviously
when it's night or cloudy you're hardly
going to get any power from the Sun for
this reason solar power plants are
probably going to be a complementary
technology to take the strain of the
main power grid until energy storage
solutions get perfected so I know what
some of you would be thinking what about
the pollution caused by the actual
production of solar panels well as it
turns out the amount of environmental
damage caused by the production is
totally dependent on who's creating the
solar panels in the first place the
environmental impact ranges from
virtually nothing all the way to pretty
devastating in places where
environmental consideration isn't a
priority
the main risk comes from the chemicals
used fabricating solar panels requires
chemicals such as sodium hydroxide
hydrofluoric acid and carbon
tetrachloride which can all lead to
dangerous waste byproducts according to
studies done by Stanford and the US
government most of the dangers from
solar panel manufacturing come from
upstream in the supply chain this is
where the raw materials are being
treated in other words it's the most
dangerous for the actual workers
producing the panels
however if regulations are followed it
is a safe work environment but the big
question is that with China being one of
the world's biggest solar panel
manufacturers are they following the
proper workplace and environmental
regulations in the past a Chinese firm
was caught dumping toxic solar panel
waste into a river while this was a few
years ago and since then from the
limited data received China is getting
much cleaner in their production
pipeline it still raises some questions
at this point it really is up to the
integrity of the firms to make sure that
they're doing the right thing
the safe recycling of old solar panels
is also an emerging industry with
Australia leading the way so on this
point if companies are BAE regulations
and solar panel recycling becomes
commonplace we could have a future with
true clean energy on a large scale
without waste it sure isn't the final
destination in clean energy but it's
rapidly becoming a valid StepStone so
why have these solar plants only been
coming online in the past two to three
years well in a video that I did a while
ago on solar I did mention that there
was a rule similar to Moore's law called
Swanson's law it's a rule of thumb about
how quickly the price of panels will
drop in relation to time
the cost of solar panels are dropping
rapidly and will continue to do so so
right now and in the future it's
enabling mass-scale
solar panel production so there you have
it the strange world of solar power
plants what was once completely
unfeasible due to cost is now becoming a
silent trend in the utility energy
generation marketplace what are your
thoughts do you think this is the right
way to go and a valid step towards clean
energy or do you have some reservations
against it let me know your thoughts in
the comments section below if you like
this video feel free to give it a thumbs
up and if you need to this channel feel
free to subscribe this video was brought
to you by Squarespace I've been building
a ColdFusion website using Squarespace
and have taken onboard some of your
suggestions one of those suggestions was
a music section where you can listen to
a collection of burn water music I'm
actually genuinely surprised at how easy
it is to build components of the website
it's very simple and intuitive if
there's anything else you want to see on
the website there's still time so you
can write your suggestions in the
comments below if you're interested in
making your own website head over to WWF
Champion and receive a free trial and
10% off your first purchase anyway this
has been - gogo you've been watching
ColdFusion thanks for watching and I'll
catch you again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one ColdFusion
are you thinking
[Music]
you